francia busca frenar a la variante
omicron el presidente manuel macrón
realiza este lunes un consejo de
ministros con el que busca aprobar un
proyecto para un nuevo pase de
vacunación el texto transforma el pase
sanitario actual y busca que sea
presentado para acceder a actividades de
ocio restaurantes bares ferias y
transporte público internacional si lo
aprueba la asamblea nacional el pase
entrará en vigencia el 15 de enero la
presentación de una prueba negativa de
kobe 19 seguirá siendo válida para
acceder a establecimientos y servicios
de salud
la medida intenta hacer frente al
repunte de kobe 19 los nuevos contagios
siguen disparados por lo que las
restricciones aumentan ahora se exige el
uso de mascarillas para los mayores de
11 años incluso al aire libre en lugares
con más de 10 personas mientras la
vacunación va a buen ritmo en 24 horas
se registraron casi 600.000 dosis la
mayoría de ellas de refuerzo según datos
del ministerio de salud entre millones
de personas en francia se han aplicado
tres dosis de la vacuna
prácticamente un tercio de la población
total del país desde el miércoles además
está abierta la vacunación a menores de
5 a 11 años